alrighty folks i went on duolingo to try
and learn how to speak woke
they do not offer this class yet so
instead my producers put together
this torturous game for me or i will
attempt to guess the correct woke
term being offered i'll be provided with
either a definition a video or an image
that pertains to the word
before we get started this video is
sponsored by giant partners now
let's play vocabulary
oh man you guys created a logo and
everything okay card
number one slang for social awareness
i mean i assume that you mean woke
[Music]
oh i got it right yeah that was an easy
one guys okay
next one you're gonna give me my money
back excuse me sir there's a young man
in here
that is a perfect example of someone
being misgendered because that is
i mean that is clearly a lady behaving
in very feminine fashion
yes
knowledge of people gained from direct
face-to-face interaction rather than
through a technological
medium oh man i feel like i should get
this one um
hmm as soon as i as the answer is
provided i will be
regretful that i didn't get this um
face to face yeah the timer's going
pressure's on i don't know where where
are we going for here
dare you she's disappointed me okay what
was the answer
lived experience oh okay i feel like
that's a bit of a miss definition
how dare you that definition was not
good it's not good
all right next
[Music]
um i mean i i understand what you're
going for here
right you're going for the there's lgbt
subtext correct but i don't underst
but i'm not sure what the terminology
you're looking for here is uh
this is all wrong every time she says
this sort of stuff just hurts me right
in my soul
oh queerbaiting yeah yeah then that's
true
yeah that is the phenomenon where there
are two characters who are not gay
but since they're in the same frame
together we're supposed to assume that
they're gay and the fact that they're
not gay is
apparently baiting the queer community
into thinking that they're gay or
something like that
yeah star wars they had this big thing
about how finn and poe were actually
secretly gay despite the fact that there
was no evidence that
either of them was gay but apparently
that was
queerbaiting ernie and bird obviously
xena princess warrior
you get this kind of stuff all the time
the assumption that all or almost
all individuals are cisgender what is
heteronormativity it could be cis
normativity
yeah yeah it's just normativity
oh yeah no my fluency with this language
is is pretty high actually
joe is white and gabby is latin x
she isn't that as they begin their
studies they enter an educational system
with statistical differences in how
students of different races
and ethnicities are treated even those
that come from identical
socioeconomic backgrounds what is this
equity
are we doing equity discrimination are
we doing um unconscious bias
this could be unconscious bias uh or it
could be implicit bias
okay
yep ain't no evidence of racism but it
must be there
if we can't find any other explanation
it must be implicit bias implicit bias
assessment tests are the biggest pile of
social science garbage ever created
trash zeros in on how some groups
whether classified by sexuality race or
ability face more struggles injustices
and systematic oppression than others
and it uses this lens's way of discourse
that's an easy one guys that's
intersectionality
are you telling me it's not that's not
intersectionality oh
um how dare you
that's sad
intersectionality is a form of identity
politics i feel like i get uh
i feel like i get at least half credit
for that i get half credit for that you
have stolen my dreams half of greta
[Music]
what cultural appropriation
that was the person from x-men
i i don't know i don't know i know
you're going for here
this is all wrong yeah she would be like
a fantastic game show host right she's
like simon
cowell but nastier oh cause like the
x-men
oh oh yeah you're digging deep on that
one
you get away with it now half agreed
okay this is the greatest city in the
history of mankind
discovered by the germans 1904
they named it san diego
which of course in german means a
whale's vagina
doesn't it mean saint diego
no yeah excellent example of
mansplaining
yeah okay perfectly obvious all right
and this one's still not cultural
appropriation um
uh this is this is the routine what's
the what's the term for this is the
routine where we're not allowed to have
actors play people
of different races white bleaching
this is all wrong
whitewashing okay i get it all right
but um just a quick note there are all
these people who are really pissed that
gal gadot is supposed to play cleopatra
in an upcoming movie
and they're like no it needs to be an
arab um cleopatra was not arab cleopatra
was of um
was a phoenician meaning greek descent
so yeah not the same thing
okay is this cultural appropriation
because that's super like giant cultural
appropriation is it not
yeah okay but it doesn't apply to them
because they're because they're woke
if you're woke you can culturally
appropriate as much as you want that's
the rule
this refers to how various types of
oppression are linked together okay this
one's intersectionality
right various types of oppression
interlinked interlinked
all right i'm on a hot streak of
wokeness here
this is jamal jamal is a boy who lives
in a poor neighborhood
he has a friend named kevin who lives in
a wealthy neighborhood all of jamal's
neighbors are african-american and all
of kevin's neighbors
are white because jamal's school
district is mostly funded by property
taxes his school is not very well funded
his classrooms are overcrowded his
teachers are underpaid
and he doesn't have access to high
quality tutors or extracurricular
activities is white privilege over here
this could be redlining this could be
white privilege
this could be um wealth inequality by
the way there's so many lies in this
video i did a whole video about it and i
still miss the chief lie which is that
schools are predominantly funded by
property taxes which they no longer are
that's not been true for a long time
um but how dare you um it's sad okay so
what was this one systemic oppression
okay again here's the problem with the
vocabulary all these terms mean the same
damn thing right systemic oppression
white privilege implicit bias wealth
inequity
right all of these things mean the same
thing so when i say all of them are just
one giant mush term i'm not even going
to explain
okay alrighty we'll get to more on the
vocabulary
in just one second first when we started
daily wire we knew that marketing
mattered
here's the thing the marketing industry
it's completely changing and continues
to change due to the pandemic
a lot of business owners are scrambling
to figure out how to adapt well
my friends over at giant partners have
marketing secrets that have been
transforming businesses
for over 20 years they're america's
number one data driven marketing agency
giant partners operates in the business
to business space they offer a variety
of business marketing solutions
like database marketing brand
development web design seo lead
generation
digital marketing services ad placement
that's just a few of their services
giant partners has worked with countless
fortune 500 companies
now they are offering their secret tips
to you and your business
giant partners is hosting a free live
webinar where they will be sharing their
marketing secrets about how to transform
your business in 2021
and beyond make sure to rsvp to reserve
your spot space is limited head on over
to giantpartners.com get your business
set up today
rsvp to their free webinar at the link
below i'll be giving away some cool free
stuff as well
only if you rsvp so don't wait rsvp
today at the link below
i am a man oh okay this could be a
couple things this could be
uh it could be dead naming
[Applause]
okay so dead naming is this thing where
if you say the words ellen page
then you have misgendered ellen page or
elliott page because ellen page now
calls
herself elliott page a man now what's
weird about this is
i'm perfectly fine with calling people
by whatever name they want you can
legally change your name although i
don't believe you can biologically
change your sex what's weird about dead
naming
is this idea that if i say bruce jenner
won gold medals in the olympics
this is now dead naming but bruce jenner
did win gold medals in the olympics
and caitlyn jenner 1-0 medals at the
olympics
because caitlyn jenner even according to
the logic of the trans community
is a woman a woman didn't win those
medals at that event because that would
be a woman defeating all the men
in all the men's events this is why i
say that transgender radical ideology
violates the laws of biology
it violates the laws of grammar and it
violates laws of physics because you're
supposed to go back in time
and elliot page was always elliot page
and was never ellen page and you were
all fooled guys when ellen page was
starring in juno
and in inception that was actually
elliott page literally the headline
when ellen page changed her name to
elliot page the headline was
juno star elliott page and i was like
wait there was no elliott page in juneau
but if you say that ellen page was in
juno
then you are now dead naming this person
it's it's
it's wild
when a company tries to seem more
environmentally friendly than it really
is
oh um well the term green is going to be
in here somewhere i'm sure
um there's no such term as greenwashing
as far as i'm aware
oh green washing okay i heard i i i
heard
uh you could you could sort of suss that
one out right because there's also pink
washing which is where
a pro-gay country like like israel
tolerance of gay people
if you show a gay person in israel then
you are considered to be pink-washing
israel because you're covering for all
their other human rights violations by
noting that israel is friendly to gay
people that's how i got that right
that's greenwashing because they're
using their environmentally
friendly practices to cover up for the
fact that they're evil capitalist pigs
no who am i um agender
um that is non-binary
[Music]
all right i'm not bad at this
sadly listen i did go to top
universities which means that i speak
the vocabulary relatively fluently
the idea that a person can be culturally
blocked from having a prominent public
platform
or a career well this would be what
accountability
culture is what they call cancer culture
see that's the
the cancer culture is actually an
anti-wolf term right so what they say
well it's so cancelled right so okay
fine cancelled is a is a woke term for
sure
cancel culture has become a right-wing
descriptor of what the left has done and
then they call it accountability culture
so
it's always a responsiveness of language
to ignore the implications of what
they're doing all the time
[Music]
oh is this um
what's the name of this i know this um
so making assumptions on the basis of
gender
how dare you that's hard it goes right
here right to your heart that's in
disgrace
toxic masculine uh toxic masculinity yep
yep yep yep so toxic masculinity is when
you make assumptions about
boys like they should be masculine the
age of men
is over so toxic masculinity doesn't
actually have any fundamental definition
if they said toxic masculinity is where
a man acts like an
then it would be like okay makes sense
like if a guy walks up to another guy on
the street just punches him in the face
toxic masculinity at work there's a
reason that there are many more men than
women who are in
jail for violent crime if by toxic
masculinity you mean what the left means
which is typically just being a dude at
all
guys being dudes like having a set then
a parent which they won't even define as
being masculine actually so i can't even
say that
but if you assume that there are certain
traits that are associated with
masculinity this is also toxic
masculinity so if you say
that men tend to defend hearth and home
which is one of the good things about
men
then this is toxic masculinity as well
having any sort of gendered
expectations of people on the basis of
their sex is toxic masculinity
and or just being a dude at all unless
you're a lady who's a dude in which case
you are just a dude but not toxic is
that the way this works something like
that
we are expecting a baby awesome
and the baby's coming soon okay i am not
pregnant
i am transgender and i
am carrying her baby i got nothing there
um i don't know complete rejection of
biological reality
how dare you
oh birthing people that's a new one you
know it's a new addition to the
vocabulary i haven't fully integrated
yet but that is a birthing person
a birthing like a woman
but a birthing person because that's a
woman who has hormone treatments in
surgery
and identifies as a as a birthing people
are you mean vagina to people and
birthing people are any
any human who is capable of giving birth
i.e a woman
but we have to pretend that some women
are not women
biologically and thus are birthing
people so it makes perfect sense a
statement action or incident regarded
as an instance of indirect subtle or
unintentional discrimination against
members of a marginalized group
such as a racial or ethnic minority it's
a microaggression that's an easy one
all right yeah yep
alrighty so not bad i mean bad for the
country
horrible for civilization well let's see
if i graduated from woke university now
i could say at this point and no matter
how i scored on the test i should
graduate from oak university because
standards
are a form of discrimination so no
matter how i did here i should graduate
graduation for everybody but we'll find
out how i did in just a moment
so there you have it folks i have
officially graduated
from wolk university
[Music]
[Applause]
now we're up to date on all the terms
you will need to know in order to
succeed in society hopefully
the woke left won't add any more any
time soon because i'm not sure i can
continue to keep up
see you next time guys